what's happening there reject nation we
have made it here to the finale of
arcane season one the monster you
created episode nine today i want to
thank everyone for uh having watched all
of our cane with us throughout this time
subscribe and click that notification
bell to get notified when our reaction
for something else comes up that you
might enjoy more importantly if you go
ahead and hit that like button that
would mean the world because yeah this
show is freaking incredible it's one of
the best shows we've seen all year full
length watch along so you sync up with
the time code over at our patreon page
over there we cover a bunch of shows at
the same tier you get the option for
reaction highlights and watch longs
included lastly thank you to the boys
over at prepper for helping us edit down
these highlights more importantly thank
you guys for being here uh still
recovering from a little cold but uh
i'm ready to do this i'm ready to watch
this let's go let's go
we're done here
we haven't even scratched the surface
silko's still out there
do you not understand i am part of this
now we're all part of it man
you've always been a part of this you
just never had to look it in the eye one
dead kid there's hundreds more where he
came from thanks to silko and thanks to
people like you who stuck their heads in
the dirt this is over not for me
oh god
[Music]
guys so much for this is over
you won't make it alone
wouldn't it just spread yeah i mean just
spray everywhere probably mutate that
kid the kids get on her too yeah
she's got any open wounds who knows
what's gonna happen you gotta do
anything about that piece of [ __ ] that
murdered my boy
let me guess
oh no
that's not the solution
what the hell is going on there
mel would you like to
[Music]
leave
no let me lick it off you
i stopped being part of this family the
moment you cast me out
why
why did you do it
because you weakened me
[Music]
let the war unfold
and you come home
take your place at my side
it's where you belong
in front of her painting and all
i'm sorry
she could have gotten to know skye a
little bit better yeah
am i interrupting
i was just wondering where has chase
been with him
you have to destroy it
the hex core
what about your disease without the hex
promise me
i promise in the pursuit of great we
fail to do good
no
but maybe just use it a little bit
longer to win this battle
you know think about the bigger picture
man
oh muni you screwed up silko
you're too young to remember what the
undercity was before it became an
enterprise
we had nothing you know what bore us
through those times
loyalty
now i'm forced to share the air with
parasites like you
today's that day you die
silke
that's a risk i've known all my life but
i still believe
in luatel
[Music]
oh
[Music]
silko he was a little like oh my god
i was little
perfect place for an ambush
and you without your hammer no longer
worthy free trade routes
blanket amnesty unrestricted access to
the hex gate sovereignty you really
think you're in a position to demand all
this i give you credit for your stunt
didn't think you had the stomach but the
big display followed by a request for
parlay you're tipping your hand
a little bit yeah if i had it my way
it'd be you running in still water
but we can't make a deal with a snake
and cut off its head
we both have our shitty parts to play
get me jinx and i'll give you your
nation of zone oh damn
oh man
there's a dilemma
so we got to caitlin man what's going on
there
it's not enough to give people what they
need to survive
you have to give them what they need to
live
money
a thousand times i'd imagine this moment
never like this all we ever wanted the
boy didn't even haggle the evander stash
what do i lose but problems
oh it all makes sense now brother
it's like a gangster new york thing
between them huh yeah
yeah absolutely like bill the butcher
and the liam neeson character
it's like what's his name
oh no
you know vander would never give up any
of them kids
nope
look where he is now
oh no oh [ __ ]
[Music]
hell yeah everyone
out rematch
oh this is gonna be fun whoever chose
the western song
great pick hmm
this is a catharsis for
god
you
that ball chills
[Laughter]
oh [ __ ]
i'm praying for a jinx
yeah
well
your god needs work
[Laughter]
that's my girl
[Music]
oh
[ __ ]
punch yeah
hell yeah the old hell yeah
my god
[ __ ]
hug
my recent unsanctioned activities in the
underground have shown me two things
i'm not fit to govern the people who
live there the red lighting is mirroring
the first episodes they're right not to
trust us
you're walking a fine line jace
with respect i don't give a [ __ ] what
any of you think of me anymore
character arc yes
be your own man jace
jace has broken a piece with silco
in exchange for the under
[Music]
what do you guys need the undercity for
really thought i buried this place
oh those eyes wanna know a secret
silko thinks he made jinx
with
all his rants and it's hard-won lessons
[Music]
someone else
but he
didn't make jinx
you did
i spent so many nights in that shitty
prison on that freezing floor hungry
bloody counting the hour the only thing
that kept me going was the thought of
getting back to you
oh man she's gonna are we
still
sisters nothing
is ever going to change that oh my god
caitlyn's like bound or something
right here he stabbed vander in the back
just like he planned to with me
oh man
that's twisted sadistic alice in
wonderland
we're missing someone
[Music]
what is that
ugh
please don't be ahead
i paid your girlfriend to visit this
morning
what did you do oh please god no you
made her a snack
no what no she just got me a biscuit
please
sheesh
i'm not that crazy
[Laughter]
seem pretty unhinged to me
powder leave her out of this
where should i sit
it could go away i knew it i freaking
knew it send her on her way in
and
you can have powder back
oh had i knew this was exactly what was
gonna happen
independence a seat at the table
all in return for you
know my daughter
i'll never forsake you
drop the gun
ugh
[Music]
she's my sister
bye she's too far gone
everyone be cool
oh no
no
[Music]
no
this poor girl
holy [ __ ] balls oh
wow
i never would have given you to them
not for anything
oh
god damn it you're perfect
[Music]
oh
jesus christ
i don't see how cheeks wins at all in
this situation
nope not now
she's making a choice
oh
goddamm
i thought
maybe you could love me like you used to
even though i'm
different
but you changed too
here's to the new us
of course you do
[Music]
[Laughter]
oh my god
i can't believe it
oh my god i can't believe this
oh
wow
wow
[Music]
whoa i'm just god goosebumps all over my
entire body right now oh there's a
cliffhanger for you
jesus christ
oh
wow well what are you gonna do
how do you rebuild next
that was one of the best seasons of
television i've ever seen in terms of
like a complete season one
you know like the story's not finished
obviously there's like it ends way too
big of a cliffhanger probably leading
into the inevitable war that everyone
feared oh yeah it's all bookended by the
loss of father figures yeah it's such a
great it's such a great gray area to
explore
throughout you know it's like what if
what if i just
stuck with her yeah you know what if she
didn't just leave in that moment
but it was so understandable the way
virial like who the [ __ ] would have
reacted
to what happened absolutely what if only
i had stuck like whoa where would we be
now
and how much better off would these
characters that we don't we don't know
but it that's to me it's like it's
everyone's is suffering from the
consequences of their own choices
from beginning to end and i i love the
i love the dinner table scene at the end
that was such a great way to bring this
all together
because every puzzle piece just worked
every piece of this giant puzzle
of different characters often times in
shows you kind of feel like nothing
really happened with this character or
this is really amount to much
and then here it's like everything just
came together in this one finale in such
a such a great way where nothing felt
wasted or unnecessary
and all coming down to the heart of the
story which is the vi and jinx
relationship because i mean it's true
it's like it wasn't silko who made jinx
like silko mainly just helps shape jinx
but jinx was born the day by abandon her
you know
and uh to be to be in that dinner table
sequence it's like wow no matter what
she chip no matter how this went down
there's no way powder would possibly win
like no way powder would come back
there's no way jinx could win it's just
impossible for her because she's she's
stuck in her own arkham asylum and
the the way they fleshed out the
relationship with her and silco where
you start off or just manipulative at
least it's perceived that way but even
in his dying words you know he's like
nah man i would have never
read you i never would have ever given
you up i love you you are perfect
damn man i felt that you know like i
don't like you but i know how much jinx
needed you who when she was alone and so
to be where she's at now and like a big
part of it's like it goes without saying
you know the reason she's alive and this
has a skill set she has
admittedly i mean a lot of [ __ ] up
things about her also in conjunction
with what happens with soccer but dinner
day
he's still racer so
and he still loved her you know so
that's the hard part about that and then
of course there's the sister dynamic
it's like no matter which way it went
there's no way she could have won
so might as well bring everything
crumbling down with her you know she's
great she's she's so encapsulating and
the voice work one thing we don't ever
talk about is the voice word but the
voice we call the show is so phenomenal
there it is
it's some of the best again like
everything about this show is some of
the best i've seen in a long time and
heard and yeah like the the nuances in
the voices and the subtleties of the
voice acting is yeah it
really brings it all that much further
to feeling
this is the most i've ever sort of
grappled back and forth feeling like i
i'm i'm so aware this is animated
because obviously but also it feels like
real people and uh since there's imbued
with so much life yeah yeah and and i
mean it's a credit to every aspect that
goes into making these and to the
writing too because they make these
characters wonderfully and painfully
gray and nuanced to the point where if
you get to know
anybody enough
you know it's gonna
present itself that they aren't exactly
who you pin them to be or or how you peg
them at first and even like soco like
you know he he starts off and you see
him and you're like oh of course this
dude's the big bad and then by the end
of it you're like yeah i mean there's a
lot that's villainous about him but you
understand where he's coming from you
understand his world you understand his
you know grip on everybody around him
and i actually i felt for everything in
that last scene even even him like as
much as
it's funny they set you up at the
beginning of the season to be like oh
man when silco gets it it's gonna be so
rewarding and it's actually
heartbreaking yeah when it happens even
though you're not necessarily sad for
him directly but even still like there's
some sympathy that they're able to glean
out of that and then the greater
pain of like
the deal worked
except it's not gonna work at all like
they he got jace got everyone to vote on
it and and you know i mean it wouldn't
would have never because he never would
have given up jinx but still i mean yeah
that was that was
extraordinarily powerful i think i mean
jace finally comes into his own
the understanding of mel is also very
fleshed out
and
yeah no no it's just it's rough because
you you do see
they they showed us such a great job of
fleshing out its own conversations
within this world
like the undercity is treated like
peasants they are treated like scum
pretty much
and
so by the time you're like especially in
this last stretch of act three
you know i really bought into the the
revolutionary side of of silko
specifically you know because at first
it just seems like power gain and
control yeah
but the revolutionary side of this whole
angle
i really started to buy like no he's
passionate about this and that's that's
where the fall between him and vander
really
stem from is their approach to
how the under city should be run and how
the under cities should be dealt with
and how they should have their own
independence you know like i i i think
they've done an amazing job on that like
silico such a greatly fleshed out
villain
you know like i i've
like that cop who died i couldn't give
two shits about him
like he's bad guys screw him he's an
[ __ ] but this but with selco
surprisingly i'm like wow the layers
they brought to him here
were so strong i mean like the animation
you could kind of just talk about
forever yes which is how insanely
expressive and i love their nightmarish
qualities they paint they just know how
to use it to hop you into character
perspective
and uh to end it all in just a wonderful
debate instead of a giant action scene i
just was so happy
and again they end a conflict with a
giant explosion i know
every conflict just one giant ass
explosion
just everything's that much worse damn
it
it's like foreshadowing it but it was a
cool use of foreshadowing too because
when you watch the first episode that
red
almost like apocalyptic blood in the air
atmosphere that this show starts with
and then it you watch this episode it
slowly just starts to become more red in
the midst of the air
and and like the clouds and such of now
that that war is coming that war is
coming again the thing that vander ander
feared that's happening that death paul
has been cast yeah yeah and uh i i love
what why it culminated to where it's at
now and how it got there you know
i mean they're probably gonna do some
season two [ __ ] where like jake survives
that
somehow he gets trapped under the right
piece of wood
him forever because they're like all
them would technically die but you know
so
they're not all going to die yeah i mean
i think mel is going to get it because
she's that would suck man
and then perhaps you'd have a jace
working with mel's mom
and and a much more embittered jace
after this too i mean because because
that's the great thing also about the
show is that of course
whatever the aftermath they're going to
draw their own conclusions and probably
just retaliate immediately yeah because
they have probably one idea of who and
why this happened
and and yeah it's like i i i'm really
excited for whatever season two becomes
and i think just be holding this whole
piece right now it's like you know yeah
there are lots of threads that are
clearly supposed to be ongoing but i
feel like where they chose to rest
it's interesting it's it's especially in
the binge era and in the era of these
kinds of shows where like yeah they're
supposed to be kind of consumed all at
once um you know
i feel like
leaving so many threads is tricky to do
when you need to also you know make it
feel like a satisfying piece as a whole
you know until the next season comes
around and i think they did that you
know it's how the developments with
victor and all the developments with
just all the relations between piltover
and zahn and now it's it seems like
that's the ultimate irony is on the eve
of of maybe peace like the ultimate war
is about to break out what makes the
show brilliant is that it's not plot
driven
the character-driven
it's all character driven and that's
what dictates the progression of the
plot yes and that's what makes it so
brilliant that's what makes it so
engrossing yeah it's the collision of
motivations and and the collision of uh
of machinations too like that that
debate at the dinner table was basically
who understands you more
you know yes is it vai who understands
powder more or is it silco who
understands jinx more that's what it all
came down to and she couldn't accept and
she chose her identity at the end yeah
and and weirdly enough by eliminating
silko she finds the irony of that is the
the elimination of silko she chooses her
identity as jinx
and so she's like wow what a great irony
you know she
she made a choice subconsciously or by
accident that they kind of play it up to
be a little bit ambiguous and how that
went like who who fired who shot
silko wasn't an accident i have just a
rage of
then i'd be curious to know you guys
think but i i feel like it was
subconsciously
subconscious for the character and
purposeful because
the whole
theme of that moment was make a choice
so i could see people thinking that it's
um
you know like oh she's just lost and
started firing around right because
there were some bullets that landed on
uh
but
uh i i still think she made a choice you
know regardless she and she wounded up
becoming the jinx yeah when it seems
like she would need that um she would
almost need that core
yeah loss and also sacrifice to
actualize herself because no matter what
if silko's still around she's still kind
of under that thumb whereas now she can
take his teaching and his you know
spirit and meld that into you know her
actualization as jinx well the
brilliance of this show is
doing
is giving you what you think you're
about to get and then totally subverting
your expectations
because i thought it was going to be a
cliche thing of
you know
who's it going to be me or caitlyn i
thought that's all it was going to turn
into especially when they're at the
dinner table and then before you realize
silko's there
and that's kind of like a secondary
thought yeah yeah
caitlyn just becomes kind of a
sick yeah
like she's here but oh that's like
that's not the main conflict that had
yeah yeah and i thought that was great
like yeah we'll give you that and we're
going to have you think it's going to be
about that but really it's not it's
really going to be between silco vi and
oh yeah that was that was just [ __ ]
brilliant so brilliant
and then heimdinger with echo now i love
that with the fire lights and then how
they because they've they've been like
making their own little advances with
technology and if there is a place where
heimdiger could belong in the undercity
it's definitely there
and i mean that could be the glimmer of
hope for season two is you know while
everything's about to go to major [ __ ]
you know hopefully maybe the fire lights
with heimerdinger's help you know
hopefully he can open back up his uh you
know exploration side you know his his
lust for you know innovation and also
would actually help these people who
he's been living above for so long and
you also see
like in terms of their character
illustrations the way they've
you started off here with vander
who
primarily mentored
vi
and you watch how she's becoming how
she's sort of
you know even that has that scene where
she remembers vander's words when she's
losing in the fight which is a great
fight by the way when she's losing in
the fight and then on the other side you
had
selko
who had jinx
you know like the they were like
brothers
who took care of the sisters yeah and
watch the product of both of them
oh how that ultimately shapes what that
shapes into a similar rift generation
down yeah it's so it's really rich
writing it's it's amazing writing and i
love how that came
like the animation and how [ __ ]
incredible that is only further
that just goes to enhance the writing
yeah
yeah and it's not the other way around
it yeah usually it is yeah no it's the
writing is the backbone of all this and
yeah there's so many things that are
dazzling and cathartic and beautiful to
behold but it's
it's a compelling story because of that
first and foremost and yeah because of
how much
how clear it is that all these different
characters motivations is what's causing
all of this you know friction and
they're really good at drawing
that
actual you know divide between
two completely different worlds under
one rule well because they don't just
talk about the worlds they show you who
the people are
and i feel better and worse oh yeah they
show you all all sides of it
so yeah there's more to come obviously
we got season two coming and
uh yeah i i thought this was a great
note to end it on for season one because
this
this culminated in the paths that have
been chosen yeah basically because a lot
of it because a lot of it's like which
which way do we go which path do we go
down
and everyone chose a path by the end
and now
it's uh because i i i consider that like
an arc in and of itself is like just it
doesn't have to end on a final note of a
character it's sometimes a an arc can be
like just what path are you going to go
down
it's kind of like the end of eight mile
you know it's like he chooses the path
and now he's on the beginning of this
new journey yeah
and i love i love where they went with
this because now it just springboards
like a whole bunch of possibilities of
where i almost don't want to play the
game because i don't want to make it any
easier for me to predict how it's going
to go yeah absolutely it's like you want
to you want more of the world and more
of all this and yet you want to preserve
how beautiful the storytelling is yeah
yeah because this is so surprising for
me that i have i have i don't guess
anything correctly
[Laughter]
no and i mean half the time i'm so kind
of engrossed that i'm not even thinking
about outsmarting it anymore yeah you
know when you're just so enthralled
and so emotionally affected
but yeah guys this is a great season of
television and uh thank you so much for
being here
hit that like button and hey let's shout
out some patrons
sequita washington
heights
mad asamer audio aircons 39 dude a
language that i don't know how to speak
kasukici
welch 18 and over william bryant
williams phil lamar eider christielia
lawson baron the garage british
pronunciation rosalie taylor's version
nick fury x
gail weathers craig ferguson jaren
warner brothers pictures stacks to crook
the captain
hook
cliff martinez rodriguez this is a
composer reference not races chris brown
busting mr crispy bacon alex b were
bacon kathleen maher bacon olivia the
wise guy
hey did you guys like that i hope you
did yeah if you didn't no refunds
all right guys thanks so much for
pledging to our patreon pitch
hopefully you enjoy the crap we got over
there yeah all of it hopefully you don't
call it crap
the content that's really what it is
crap tent crap content
[Music]